yeah welcome to this video playing ARMA
gr and the funny age 6 line I I have fun
played that in this recent tournament in
Austria instant indian international
master and jumps quarter relatively easy
draw in fact I'm somehow a bit regretted
that I'm that I made this drawing
because before the game I thought oh and
draw is quite ok save some energy you
don't that don't term overdo things down
and turn well and then I offered the
draw after 12 moves and what he was
thinking about if you should accept it a
thought waiter it isn't is a good
position now I should have played the
plate this position instead of offering
a draw okay so um we have some exchanges
already it's a very typical position for
the car con not why didn't play in a
very aggressive way I want to exchange
the sea against the deep own before I
place 95 it takes I'll take with the
queen of course and this this whole
position should be um around equal maybe
White has a very slight pool because he
is better centralized at the moment
no yeah white has got this legendary
almost queenside majority quite often it
it doesn't really mean much it very much
depends on them on the concrete
positional features okay b6 you will
play rock d7 and this is not great so
better better retreat prepare 95
yeah I don't think white has any edge
here
yeah it's okay i was just thinking maybe
a four or something but this is
certainly a ride huh okay I don't want
that I can play F 6 35 now or f6 and 93
how interesting
okay yeah of course I'm naughty 595 but
can I go g5 yeah why not let's win some
space in fact this position is ok for
black I'm I'm even I'm even more
comfortable here I'm better centralized
and have better central control and this
is just on top so the night wants to go
to see three I didn't write it up play
93 so quickly I think this was a mistake
okay time playing it so quickly maybe I
should have considered some other other
options okay but a form is this is
interesting try to await this this this
is technically shaky night f4
neither form yeah but drew could see two
okay I can't take first I can take first
and now maybe maybe night f form thus
intermediate check all the time so he
needs to hist he must surrender the
default now like Roxy to and then I have
both open files just nice okay should I
take and then look here ugh d three or
something yeah check but it is it is a
nice position why not I control both
open lines
f3 maybe I'll have FF five I keep the
activity by controlling both open lines
okay he can he can try that but
yeah I can first activate even more
after c5a playbooks III so that it
cannot go you cannot go b5 without
giving away the porn okay so look is
seven maybe okay this is a good good
spot for this move he takes takes rook
a7r take before so we he has some
doesn't have a very attractive doesn't
have very attractive options here rook
be one probably back brooke a2 b1
why not a to be one looks like the only
move maybe rugae to but don't know
didn't Oh interesting choice c 70
interesting
okay I need to need to take check your
interesting defense I have the porn but
this is not enough not enough to win yes
Lucas is rather active Sam check check
he will probably be able to draw this Oh
decide I don't know check king of 55
rugae three this is very important so
now it's probably it so that it is still
it wrong but of course I can I can try
check
f5 that's rook that's rookie is six
check check now there are they I think
this is critical for white because the
king is cut off i go here and this first
and then look III check rook f2 f2 f3
white for things on time yeah and i
think a pretty interesting endgame i'm
not sure about his defense here he is
clearly worse but I thought he just
shook a be one I mean it is clear let's
say let's say after that check then I
don't know our invasion here why just
struggling but um I don't know maybe it
was good what he did it was an active
defense check yeah this was a good
defense actually he only needs to play
it differently check check check this is
probably all right but I don't know
about g-form I don't know what you form
maybe you can just play an arm in a more
yeah let's say passer fashion but it's
probably okay why not g3 or something I
don't I don't make any big progress here
the the rock is always cutting the king
or harassing him with check so this is
probably a draw
check this I don't know of course and
this is what I actually forgot to
mention in the video here he should do
it should do that check this is good
yeah I saw this in the video but forgot
to say it because f5 made a son as an
issue and I need to take and this is a
draw quite quite easily even I have no
way to progress here is this King is
helping in the defense and in the game
he always poops his king was was cut off
him and this is the problem I'll get the
pawn him and his King cannot help
alright thanks for watching